i was stabbed up i was batted i was hit
by a truck but that was part of my life
as a hit man
[Music]
hey i'm john alain ex-enforcer for the
gambino family hitman
and i'm here to play never have i ever
never have i ever
killed someone i have
in the past you can't take back what you
did you can only move forward but that
was part of my life as a hitman enforcer
for the gambino family and some of the
things i did for the gambino family
i killed with the bat i killed with a
knife i killed with a gun it was part of
the life for me to
enforce some of our rules and laws when
i was sent by
guys that i work for personally never
have i ever
nearly been killed i have unfortunately
i was
stabbed up a couple of different
occasions shot i was hit by a truck i
was also baseball batted and piped and
on several occasions
different organizations tried to machine
gun me on the corner of my house another
time
guys involved with the mafia tried to
shoot me down the block from my house
one occasion i was in the hospital for
about six weeks
i got out of the hospital i was probably
about 80 pounds that was just part of my
everyday life unfortunately
never have i ever refused to kill
someone
i have at the time john gotti senior was
in
mcc manhattan he asked his brother gotti
to come back
and see me at the club after a jailhouse
visit and asked me to kill a guy
as a favor i believe he was part of or
one of the guys that killed my friend
greg ryder that the
body was never found that he was
supposedly chopped up and disappeared
i refused to do any kind of favor for
him to help him beat his case
while he was in jail for several murders
during my enforcing days i was also
accused of
killing a rabbi hired two people in
jersey to murder his wife while he had
an affair it was big news in
philadelphia and south jersey i was
questioned accused of that murder
later on i was cleared they found the
two guys that did it they told on each
other the rabbi went to prison for life
the detectives at the time when they
came to see me you guys know what i do
for a living
you think i'm a hitman but i wouldn't
kill a woman i'm the guy that would go
after the guy that killed a woman i
would kill that person
so i think afterwards my reputation talk
for itself they knew i wouldn't do
things like that and i never got accused
of something like that again
my hits were involved only with street
guys mob guys
nothing outside of that never have i
ever been to prison
unfortunately i've been to prison my
whole life i've been off parole
the last couple of years was the first
time since i'm 17 i've been off parole
i've been in prison
in florida in new jersey on a cruise
ship
in brazil probably 40 prisons i did a
book called prison rules with nick
christopher
it's a handbook actually about the
pitfalls of the street and how to avoid
them how to avoid trouble inside prison
if unfortunately you find yourself there
when i went to jail in brazil it was
nothing like united states prison
because it's
almost like concentration camp like in
the prisons i was in you get about 100
some guys that get killed a year
there's guns inside the prisons there's
machetes and there's
occasions where i myself had to stab
several guys
in prison in brazil but it was more of a
torture
situation not here where you're housed
and confined there you're tortured you
beat
completely different situation in third
world country i think when you
grow up in the life i grew up
fortunately for me my father trained me
as a kid
to accept getting hurt as bad as they
are you have the mentality
to never quit you're going to survive it
somehow you're going to get out of it
you're going to try to escape and you
have that no quit attitude it was a life
where i hurt and killed a lot of people
it's the part that took me to another
level that most guys don't go to even
though they talk they'll do this or do
that like most mob guys if you go
through the
accounts and see how many people they
actually heard shots that very few of
them have
done that kind of work it's only a
handful of guys like myself that do that
kind of work
never have i ever suffered ptsd
[Music]
i have i think anybody that's been in
wars or seen the violence i saw it's
impossible
not to suffer from ptsd unless you're a
sociopath the toll of
people i hurt killed which i think took
a toll on me mentally and i started
seeing therapists probably for about 30
years same woman
somebody i relied on to help me not lose
my temper when people are pushing my
buttons and at times
i yell i scream but i don't react the
way i used to it's okay to think the
same way
just don't react the same way my
lifelong dream
is to continue helping every kid not to
stay in prison to get out and live a
good life
never have i ever regretted killing
someone
i have not and the reason why i say i
have not and i think that's going to
surprise a lot of people because if i
didn't come to this point in my life
i don't think i could ever save all the
kids lives i'm saving now
so i think for whatever god's plan was
for me
it was for me to get to this point the
lowest point you could probably get into
your life
and reflect back on the lives that you
took the people that you hurt but in the
long run
i think i'm gonna save more lives by
doing the things like i'm doing now the
johnny and gene
podcast show and all the talks and a
second chance program for
teenagers and young adults i think you
know
some of the rewarding stories that
people ask me there's a young boy who
became a my thai fighter champion his
name
sam greenfield i mentioned them plenty
of times on different podcasts the shows
i've done he had a friend that was
killed in gang violence in the uk
so i flew over the uk and sam's father
got in touch with me
we started speaking and i started
talking to his son and his son
turned around his life instead of trying
to get revenge and kill the guys that
killed his friend
he changed his life he started helping
kids advocating kids became a champion
fighter
and he just received a reward this year
for advocating for young adults
so it's something i'm really proud of i
changed a guy's life who's saving a lot
of guys lives
it really makes a successful and it
helps me to move forward doing what i'm
doing i can't
look back and regret it because i can't
take it back
and it's something that'll just
frustrate me mentally and i think the
only thing i could do was use what i did
in such a bad past
to make such a good future
[Music]
you